Here we are down in our post function.
In our success case we want to behave a little differently.
What we want to do is make an art.
A--that's going to be our art--
equals a new instance of art.
We're going to pass in title equals title
and art equals art.
We don't need the pass in created.
Because of the autonowadd, we'll automatically get that property.
So we're going to create a new instance,
and then to store this instance, we say a.put.
This will store our new art object in the database.
When we're done, we're going to redirect to the front page
so we don't have that annoying reload message--
the resubmit your form--if we hit reload.
Okay, so let's go ahead and give this a test.
Here I am in our browser.
Now what should happen is when we submit a valid title
and piece of art text,
we should store it in our database.
Okay, so I'm going to type in a title.
This title will be camel,
and then I'm going to put some art in our text box here,
which is a camel that I copied off of that ASCII art site,
and I'm going to click submit.
I click submit.
We're back on the front page, so we think it worked,
but we really have no way of knowing for sure right now.
So let's add the rest of this feature,
which is going to draw our artwork at the bottom of our form.